this is Startalk all right Thomas
Valenzuela and wants to know this Thomas
you gotta miss that's a cool last name
that is Valenzuela balance when you
can't but you can't beat that yeah I
used to love that picture for the dodge
yeah yeah yeah all right so does the
rotation of the galaxies give us north
and south orientation in the universe
based on something similar to the
Coriolis effect and if that is the case
could it be used as a reference to
measure distances and our position
versus the equator of the universe no
okay next question
no there's some interesting backstory
here yes so in physics we have an
unambiguous way of how to define what is
north really yes okay please so North
has meaning only in things that rotate
okay all right if I put a book in front
of you say what's north it's not means
nothing okay rotate something now take
your right hand curl your fingers in the
direction of thing is rotating okay then
stick up your thumb mm-hmm
that's north guides you okay got you and
so that's how we can say if something is
rotating upside down right relative to
north because you'd have to twist your
curl it or all the fingers and now it's
rotating in that devalue the thumb is
pointing down split it down okay so
that's how we define rotation we did not
know that the galaxy was a rotating
thing until long after we had like named
it and why is it called galaxy get
galactose is Greek for milk
that's the Milky Way going across the
night it just look like a streak of
white across sugar blackened night sky
not did anything was literally milk but
it was the poetic reference to it right
and so so that's the galaxy and now if
you learned that it is a flattened
system and then you want to ask does it
have a north and a South we astronomers
in the early day
assigned the north pole of the galaxy to
the pole of the galaxy that happened to
be in the northern hemisphere of the
earth of earth sky
gotcha alright because we're seeing it
from the north or top part of our rather
our reference we would later learn which
way the galaxy was rotating and it turns
I was turning the other way gotcha
so we are stuck calling the North Pole
of the galaxy the opposite of what our
laws that we made for ourselves to
define it as such would give us God said
yes so in other words the the what we
say is the South Pole of the galaxy is
in the north what we say is the North
Pole of the galaxy is in the Northern
Hemisphere sky but it's actually the
smaller galaxy yeah yeah so yes we can
orient the galaxy but we the universe
we've never found a way to orient it
there's no patch of material in one
direction or another an axis a
distribution of a claim right none of
that the stuff is like pretty random as
far out as you go that's cool man yeah
so we could do that here on earth
because we have all of those things to
measure and look as the north pole of
the solar system which weighs all our
all the planets dragging around the Sun
as we see the Sun as the center which
weighs the Sun rotating so that Sun has
a North Pole everybody's got a North
Pole got yeah that is cool and that's
because we didn't know it was we didn't
know it was rotating we we had to
discover the galaxy because we're in it
right very it's like how do what your
mother looks like if you're in an embryo
within her womb that's so funny you
don't know so one of the last things we
discovered was the galaxy what the hell
we look like in the galaxy what great uh
what a what a great example how do you
know what your mom looks like before
you're born yeah you have no idea right
well you know her boy you get a selfie
stick and put it out what I'm just that
there could be a way to do it that's all
so I'm saying oh my god selfie stick
this is Startalk